if children are exposed to two languages
before the first birthday this has
unanticipated benefits you can measure
them in the laboratory so when you bring
these babies in they are better able to
for instance resolve conflict cues they
are better able to unlearn a rule that
they learn so for instance if they
learned that pulling on a string leads
to a mobile moving or something else
that they like if the rule suddenly
changes they're more rapidly able to
resolve that conflict and learn the new
rule and so one thing that's interesting
is that there seem to be ancillary
benefits that come from learning a
second language that don't seem to have
anything to do with the learning of the
language itself a relatively advanced
version of this is something that
psychologists call the Stroop task if I
show you the letter the word red except
it's written in green ink and you have
to say well what color is that in and it
says red and you have to resist the
impulse to say red and you say it's in
green ink children who are bilingual are
better at the Stroop task they're better
at resolving those kinds of cues there
are other benefits that come from
learning a second language as well one
benefit that comes out of it that you
might not expect is that children who
know two languages are better what is
called theory of mind and theory of mine
is a phrase that refers to being able to
understand plays on another person's
mind so let's say if I can see that
you're looking at the door and you're
thinking about who's behind the door or
you're thinking about lunch or whatever
it might be if I have a good model of
what you're thinking about that's the
general capacity called theory of mind
and bilingual children have been
demonstrated to have a little bit better
theory of mind and that's interesting
because theory of mine has itself many
ancillary benefits like having empathy
for other people it's even been
demonstrated that dementia the loss of
cognitive function as we get older is
delayed by an average of about four
years and people who are bilingual
compared with people who do not speak a
second language and so you get lots of
lots of benefits from being bilingual
and this persists throughout life it's
even been demonstrated that that
whatever demands being bilingual makes
on our brains continue all the way
through life
you